well this is pretty iconic I am such a
fan of you I don't think we've ever met
before so I'm super excited even though
this is virtual to meet you because like
I said you are somebody who is doing
incredible things for the queer
community and it's just such a pleasure
that you're doing this with ET Canada oh
thank you it's so nice to meet you
Dallas thanks for having me of course
anytime listen first and foremost you're
helping kick off a queer Music Festival
here in Canada lavender wild there are
some great artists alongside yourself G
flip girl in red and so many others this
Festival is unlike a lot of festivals
where it is put on by queer people with
queer performers and that's just so
important for the lgbtq plus Community
uh why do you think this Festival is
important to have
well I I can't believe it's taken so
long to have a festival like this I've
been saying for years that we should be
having a festival like this and I'm so
proud um of Toronto for hosting this
incredible festival and I'm so lucky to
be a part of it it's going to be a very
special weekend but it's just so
important to have representation and
also it's so important to be able to
have festivals that can break like my
like-minded people together and
um an amazing Community together to
celebrate themselves especially during
Pride so I'm very very honored to be a
part of it I'm so excited to see so many
of my peers girl in red and Daya and
g-flip and there's so many amazing
artists that are going to be performing
this is uh I think we can say this will
be queer Joy this really is Queen July
it is queer Joy to the fullest extent a
thousand percent uh you've been in
Canada many times a lot of times when I
talk to people they say Canadian fans
are some of the best fans in the world
is that something that you've
experienced too because I know you have
so many Die Hard fans here
I would agree I'm
um yeah I had a sold out show in Toronto
which was so much fun and uh I love
playing in Toronto and my mom's from
Montreal and so uh maybe I'm biased but
I love I love doing any shows I've done
in Canada whether it's Vancouver
Montreal anywhere
um the Canadian fans really show up and
um I also love Canada so I'm also biased
will your mom be making an appearance
she'll actually be performing girls like
girls for me I'm just gonna be doing
background background vocals you know no
I'm excited she's coming out and we're
gonna have like she she also lives in
Toronto so she's gonna bring me around
we're gonna have like a little like
family day which will be nice that is
super nice listen there has been so much
going on in your career you were
absolutely killing it on so many fronts
it will be almost a full year since you
dropped Panorama and a full year since
for the girls music video came out where
you iconically introduced yourself and
your partner Becca Tilley in a music
video uh how would you say this era has
changed you as an artist
I can't believe it's been a year I mean
directing the music video for for the
girls and having Becca and I share our
love with everyone has been such a
wonderful experience and
um it's been really it's it started a
new chapter of getting to share that
part of our lives with everyone
um but I'm so excited I mean I I was
able to do my Panorama tour this year I
have my book girls like girls out May
30th and um so it's been a very exciting
journey and I'm excited to to kick it
off you know at Echo beach in Toronto
and
um do it with a bunch of queers and I'm
such a fan of drag I loved seeing you on
RuPaul's secret celebrity drag race and
now it's like this full circle moment
where you're going to be again budge on
RuPaul's Drag Race which would be like
the biggest dream in my life to be able
to sit behind that panel and share some
insight and love and support what was
what is that entire experience been like
working along some alongside somebody
like RuPaul
it was a really unique experience
celebrity guest judge they don't tell
you anything so if you and I mean I shot
it like over a year ago so you like sign
all these NBAs and stuff so
um but it was it was a wonderful
experience when you get to go on set and
then
um you don't really know what's going on
in the actual show so when it aired and
I watched it I was like oh there's a lot
of drama going on I was like oh this is
happening and this is happening but when
you're a guest judge you just show up
and you know you watch The Runway and
watch them slay and then you know give
your critiques and you leave so but I
I've had such an amazing time just
getting to come back to RuPaul's Drag
Race and experience new things like
obviously uh being able to experience
drag and then being able to be a guest
judge was a really cool experience and
I'll do it anytime you are also really
out there being an outspoken Ally for
all of these drag artists recently in
Tennessee of course how important is
that for you to use your voice in that
way
it's extremely important I think it's in
our human nature to show up for one
another and to show up
um and know the difference between right
and wrong and
um you know it's really unfortunate that
um
in the US of a we are trying to scare
people
um and silence people through fear and
it's not okay and um we won't stop until
we're all able to be our true authentic
selves and feel safe to do so
um we have a very long way to go and so
it's very important when you have an
opportunity to to do what's right and
hopefully be safe in doing so you you
try to navigate it the best you can I
mean my show in Nashville was very
challenging and
um
my incredible drag queens felt
comfortable and and moving forward with
the show and so we did it and
um you know we're not going to let them
silence us your debut novel girls like
girls is a coming-of-age story how long
did it take for you to be like okay this
is done I'm done with it let's put it
out into the world
and process I mean even though like once
I turn in the final Pages even just like
designing the cover and designing The
Binding and choosing the font and
choosing the style of the fun and it was
like I mean it just was endless I mean
honestly we the finished product we've
finalized like maybe a month and a half
ago so it's been a long process uh but
I've been so excited to share the novel
with my fans and hopefully new fans
girls like girls has been so important
to so many people through the song and
then the music video
um one day hopefully it'll be a feature
film but
um because it's that part has taken so
long it felt like the novel uh was an
important next step and my My Hope as
well is for young teens or kids trying
to navigate
um their identity and self-discovery and
also trying to find Hope for their
future they're able to find girls like
girls and read the book and and feel
seen and heard
um because a lot of people
um all over the world are not safe under
their own roof to to share who they
truly are and so my hope for this book
is to to ignite that hope and to to help
people continue to believe in themselves
in their future
so when you're on the road are you the
type of person that's writing new music
on the road because listen we are ready
for new music
well I actually have a new song
um I to answer your question I I wrote
new music prior to leaving tour uh
because again it's just too hard to
write new music and be touring at the
same time
um but that song's out and I have more
new music coming so it's been really
amazing to get to share new songs uh
with my fans uh while being on the road
so it's
um hope you enjoy if you haven't checked
it out you should check out Greenlight I
think everybody is going to enjoy green
light that is for sure listen we uh the
showrunner of Wizards of Waverly Place
wanted Alex to be bisexual we recently
read which would be an incredible idea
to me and have a relationship with your
character Stevie just saying that would
have been iconic I don't know I think so
and it got my mind thinking Hmm I would
love to hear a Haley and Selena collab
uh could that ever happen down the line
I would love that I think I've I've
reached out to Selena a couple times
trying to get her on a song or two so I
love her music as well so I feel like
the fans would freak out if we did a
song together so I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Keep uh hitting her up and see see what
happens but I'm glad the fans I'm glad
the staliks fans were getting what they
deserve and it's just been so funny to
me because I you know when I shot those
four I was only in four episodes and I
shot those four episodes I had no idea
that
um I don't know at least 10 years later
we would still be uh
high off of staleks from Wizards of
Waverly Place
listen people hang on to those things
I know well it's funny because people
are like oh well
character guy and I was like no I just I
just was gay and I was young and so I
was probably giving her the eye and they
got it on camera and you know one thing
you know whatever
the story takes on its own life you know
that's right the fan fiction the fan
fiction listen it's been incredible the
fan fiction has taken over